I love Turkish food but I've never ever
had the chance to cook your property so
there's a first time for everything and
tonight I'm going back to the floor
inside this Turkish question to be a
sous chef at the forefront of service so
I can't afford any cock-ups Kazan is one
of London's finest Turkish restaurants
with an incredibly busy dinner service
at the moment we've got about 90 booked
in I think it's gonna be really busy
really tough the busy kitchen is run by
head chef asam he is exacting standards
and a fiery temper sounds familiar
apparently I stand a man not easily
impressed it's putting fire with fire
really so it could either be a big
explosion in there or or they'll get on
great hello hi how are you Hassan ooh
stir yes chef yes rooster is the boss
yes
all the starters the desserts are being
prepared in advance of service I'm going
to learn three classics dolma yeah
they're vine leaves and this stuff with
her Brice after quickly be showing the
intricate technique it's my turn very
very difficult
roll them nice and tight they're gonna
be steamed after but it takes me two
minutes to make one door one the chef's
here can make one in ten seconds quite
sweet I'd love to stay in practice but
sheperson
have different ideas so inside the filo
pastry guard cheese darkness cheese feta
cheese baby spinach right this kind
making correctly no one can pick these
skills up immediately the chef's here
take years to perfect their techniques
but only have a couple of minutes okay
I'm a you're a tough cookie to pleaser
astana stayed the hardest for last the
traditional dessert but clobber this man
is a clever specialist yes it's all he
does all day
Wow pastry has never been my strong
point unrolling it this five takes years
to perfect
yep just wrong yeah put a little bit on
Florida's up yes you with service
looming hasn't happened the time for me
to make mistakes blimey he's got less
patience than me after rolling the
sheets as thinly as possible they cut
them layered into a baking tin
transparent almost see-through it
clarified butter is at it it goes in the
oven and will be sweetened with syrup
and nuts when cooked delicious end of
round one
next up service